oh hey everybody welcome to my second
channel this first video is a me
tattooing fans terribly and then I
follow up with them eight years later to
see how they really felt about it it's
going to be a lot of fun around here
thank you for coming over I never used
one of these before
it's time to start I get type I'm doing
it right
I feel like a Mario optimist
now on this lick it
so I'm here in Boise Idaho and I thought
it'd be a cool idea to tax you my
autograph on someone on stage and I
accidentally tattooed Stevo
I'm totally gonna fix it Dave dude I
mean real same they're [ __ ] are you
stoked on your new tattoo awesome rocks
oh yeah you it's been eight years since
that and Dave let's see that [ __ ]
thing so you never regretted that I
completely ruined your arm no never no
you really are lying
Oh created a great friendship between
you and I man that's right dude
so what's it like been living with Stevo
TAS use for the last eight years
depressed down even when our boy tattoo
ladies machine but kind of handle
anymore [ __ ] it [ __ ] it I have a man
that's [ __ ] painful I'm gonna live
with it from the rest of my life now I'm
actually really happy with all my
tattoos I love all my tattoos I love the
[ __ ] I Adam or ima make me look like a
bit of a crazed fan you know but I'm
quite happy that I came good friends
with Steven and you know I can actually
laugh about it yeah could you even
believe how happy those guys were now
those are my buddies we have Brad and
Dave thanks for being a part of this
video and everybody else thank you for
coming to my second channel watching the
first video and of course there's going
to be more so subscribe well